Now that we have actually created that widget, what we need to do now is set this up so that when the game
starts we display this and we do this using this following bit of code.
Now one of the cool things about this following bit of code is anytime you want to display a
UMG widget to a user you do this setup. First we create the HUD,
we set a variable to it so that we can recall it or use it later, and then we add it to our
viewport. So what we're going to be doing is we're going to edit our vehicle game mode.
So let's come back over here to unreal. We are going to close this down and we are going to go
control spacebar to open up our content browser. We're going to come down to our vehicle template,
our blueprints, and we're going to look for our advanced vehicle game mode. There we go.
And we want this to happen at event begin play so as soon as the level starts. So what we're
going to do is we are going to create widget and the widget that we want to create is going to be
our HUD UMG. And then next what we're going to do is I'm just going to right click on this and
promote this to a variable and we're going to call this HUD ref so we have a reference to our
HUD in case we need it. And then what we need to do is we need to add to view and let's just
disable context sensitivity so add to viewport. There we go. And we are going to add this
reference to our HUD to our viewport and then we are going to set timer by event. So let's go
ahead and compile and once we're done we can now kick it over into our next section which
is going to involve testing and then further UMG creation and setup so that we have
a level to go to when this starts and some options when it ends.